alors insecticides à ces moines
purificateurs d'eau c'est bon sparadrap
j'ai l'impression d'oublier quelque
chose ou lui en suis responsable
pénalement pas la papa tu savais comme
amazon il serpente wasquehal écrit et
gore
vous êtes prêt on se met en route car là
où sont morts sans moi j'vais le voyage
avec vous inquiète pas mon grand on va
veiller sur toi et va tu as laissé venir
bien sûr je lui ai promis qu'elle aurait
un rôle dans le spectacle quoi vous êtes
en retard dans l'absolu mais pour des
musiciens non attendez vous de vous y à
l'école bocaly je vis un objectif jeunes
de ces partis et c'est qui qui va jouer
je pense aux pompiers